bjj training and you're worried about
injuries that makes sense actually i got
some i've got to ask this question a few
times
people that rely on their hands to work
uh one guy is a professional actually
two guys were professional guitarists oh
yeah yeah and they're sketched out about
doing jiu jitsu uh
anybody that has a job that relies on a
lot of physicality
you you are at risk because you're you
know you're doing a sport no
injuries absolutely happen in jiu jitsu
it is a contact sport and you can get
injured while you're doing it
you can get injured in any sport that
you do yeah
any sport that you do the the worst
my i hurt my knee i had 80 tear on my
mcl
did it surfing yeah you know been healed
hooked by dean lister
thousands thousands and thousands of
times never had a knee injury
i'm out surfing and hurt my knee so you
can get
hurt doing anything
but so you have to be careful
right and i think one of the best one of
the most critical ways to
be careful in jiu jitsu is by make sure
that you're picking the right training
partners
yeah because there's some knucklehead
training partners at every gym
and they're they're a 20
22 year old male
uh who has a lot of testosterone
and has a very sensitive ego and so he's
looking just to
crush everyone so you gotta watch out
for that guy and actually i shouldn't
i shouldn't actually paint that so broad
brush because
there's plenty of people that are that
are older people with a big ego and
younger people there's people there's
just basically you got to watch out for
these knuckleheads that are going to go
crazy
yeah some people don't know better too
you know they're just they just happen
to be big and strong
and they're not being knuckleheads
they're just like yeah they're getting
it you know they're telling me to grab
the arm and pull
i'm trying to pass that guard i don't
know that much technique i'm just going
to go hard
yeah no you're right they're they're
they're not intentionally being
aggressive
but you just is an aggressive sport and
if you happen to be 260 pounds
that can be problematic so you want to
fly and and
i know it sounds weird if it goes some
purple belt that's just going to run
through me no actually you do
the purple belt the chance of you
getting hurt by a purple belt are
infinitely less than you getting hurt by
a white belt absolutely true
and the higher you go up the more
accurate that is unless of course you're
you're uh you're a problem right or
you're a bully
and there needs to be a regulatory
situation happening in which case a
black belt is not going to
you know he he won't injure you though
that's the thing
it's like true i think when you enter
fighting sports
punishment isn't being beat up you get
beat up that's part of the game
true it's more it's more of like an
embarrassment thing
or like just like
yeah like they're gonna wear you out you
know or make you look like you suck or
i don't it's it's it's more of like a
lesson thing in that way
it's not like getting beat up yeah i i
agree with you now another piece of this
and i i this is just a reality okay
doing stand-up you have a higher chance
of getting hurt
like doing takedowns going hard
takedowns yeah either judo
style takedowns or resting style
takedowns you have a higher chance of
getting a knee injury or an ankle injury
there's no doubt about it
so be careful just think about what
you're doing there
um with with stand-ups you know if
you're a person that's
you know you gotta you gotta learn some
basic takedowns absolutely but
do you need to step in there night after
night and get your full-on wrestling
practice together and
as you if you're a 43-year-old person
that you know
you're a 43 year old cop that's working
to beat you you know you need to know
takedowns don't get me wrong
you need to train them you need to study
you need to make sure you know how to do
them do you need to out wrestle somebody
in a in a wrestling situation probably
not you know you're
you're not going to need to do that so
just use caution
with takedowns um make sure you know how
to do them
but as you get to where you want to
not get injured is your one of your
primary
thoughts in training then just be
careful to stand up
um obviously do a good warm-up and this
is something i'm
just the worst uh
perpetrator of not warming up well i
like to warm up by rolling
so and actually now i do usually do one
round where i'm just kind of chilling
and just kind of rolling flow
but i used to not even do that it's just
like clap hands and go
so don't do that obviously keep your ego
in check and i'll say another thing and
i was talking about this with greg train
the other day because greg train
popped his rib yeah and
he was just saying to me his ribs
recovered now but he was saying to me
you know he's like i think you don't get
injured because you work out all the
time
and i'm like i agree with you 100 yeah
so
i believe that you should work out on a
regular basis and somebody just asked me
do you train and lift on the same days
as yeah absolutely i train and lift i
train left every day so
get your workout program going on you
know make sure you maintain that some
people
when they start doing jiu jitsu they're
they're going so crazy
that they use all this muscle and so
they go like i'm not going to work out
because i'm just getting a workout no
wrong answer
keep working out a matter of fact you
should and i always
encourage working out lifting doing your
metcon doing whatever
before you do jiu jitsu that's what i do
i want to be tired when i show up to g2
and fight in a worse scenario
you know make it harder for myself i
don't want to show up and
and be all fresh and like that's going
to happen every day
no i like to be tired worn out
stressed system and then show up and
still get after it on the mats
yeah that part's pretty advanced though
to do it like that
i gotta say i mean being new is the
question i've done that the whole time
yeah and i've done that too before and
good yeah you do you work out after
you lift weights after you train jiu
jitsu i've done both okay
what do you do normally i do one and
like i don't do
two days normally oh so when you roll
into the mat you're like all fresh
in a matter of speaking yeah fresher
than i would be if i did a workout
before yes
put it that way that's cool no as of
right now that is how it is yes for sure
but before and even when i was training
for competition and stuff oh yeah
and even yeah like maybe like two years
three years ago maybe um yeah i'd work
out i'd do the workout first
and then go roll out like in the evening
i think that's the plan
um as much as you can work on your
flexibility
yeah and this is something that i again
this is a big fail area in my book
i'm not flexible as i should be and
you if you are more flexible your injury
levels are going to go down
yeah so you know stretch and
it's really easy stuff that you know
everyone says to do you know when you're
sitting there on the mat even when
you're sitting in the mat and the
teacher's teaching
you know trying to go to the lotus
position try and you know just do
stretches while you're doing that
if you're sitting around just stretch
while you're sitting around while you're
working on your computer sit in a way
that you're getting some kind of stretch
so so stretch and be flexible as much as
you can
now another thing i kind of talked about
guitarists and
anybody you know a surgeon anybody
that's working with their hands and
wants to protect their fingers
i would recommend maybe emphasizing more
nogi
where you're not grabbing onto that ghee
all the time yeah yeah
and again fingers get caught up in there
any twists or something too you can yank
them
yeah every time pretty much it's fairly
common um
i actually my worst finger injury was
actually nogi
so that's and i only did it a couple
months ago which is just and it was just
a bizarre it was a bizarre incident i
it was one of those things so that's why
it's really hard for me to just straight
up encourage somebody that
needs their fingers like no no dude
don't worry you're not gonna get no no
no you can't get her now
i've had one finger injury you know
significant finger injury
in 20 plus years so you can get a finger
injury
cutting the carrots on the you know in
the kitchen
so you know you got to be careful
but there's no guarantee that you're not
going to hurt and i'll tell you and the
other thing is
i will say this you got some chance of
getting injured right
but there's also some massive physical
and mental benefits
that will likely outweigh the injuries
the perceived injuries or the possible
injuries that you might get
so you're going to be healthier your
fingers are going to be stronger
yeah i mean yeah you might get some
injured fingers uh
but you are also going to have fingers
that are stronger your grip is going to
be
stronger so that's beneficial your mind
needs to be stronger your cardiovascular
systems can be stronger so there's a lot
of
benefits to jiu-jitsu
that outweigh in my mind the possibility
of having an injury yeah
i mean the possibility of having a
catastrophic injury
is pretty small especially if you train
smart it really is
agree i absolutely agree yes and when
you think about it
even of the people that you know over 20
years that's a lot of people that you
know
who's had a any kind of major injury
well really if you count it depends what
you count as a major injury
but you know if you blow out your knee
that means you're gonna be down you're
gonna be six months of surgery or
whatever
surgery and six months of rehab and then
another three months before you can try
that's you know that's a year yeah and
and that could be some people consider
that catastrophic
injury i know i would be devastated but
at the same time
you know i heard i got neck surgery i
was out for a bit don't even remember it
now flash in the pan who cares whatever
yeah deal with it i played more guitar
during that time you know what i mean
good times yeah and the and in in
reference to this question
man this is anything you do guys on the
basketball court all the time
oh i'll go up for just recreational
basketball pick up game weekend whatever
block their knee ankle whatever you know
i had
i mean i've been in the game what 12
years i'd won
because i was getting nuts in a
tournament bicep tear
major injury you know alfred you know
year or whatever
but other than that never been injured
because of a submission a lot of
training too
yeah in full speed training competition
like everything in
as far as the mission holds go never
been injured
in a submission you know how like as a
double yeah you should
definitely if you're a smart judge
player you'll never get injured from
somebody trying to submission on you
because you tap
yeah you tap and look it's not gonna not
hurt you know if you talk too late
usually it's just you get hurt
maybe your shoulders kind of whatever
for a week or
but you can still train you it's not an
injury put it that way yep
you know and even if yeah even if you're
you're big small
i think that's pretty common it's really
rare that i see
oh my acl is out because of a heel hook
maybe in competition because you're
trying to win
you weren't trying to tap there's a few
okay but yeah generally speaking
it's surprising almost that it's that
safe
it is when you consider when you
consider what the objective of the sport
is to break
and destroy people's limbs the fact that
it rarely happens
it just really happens yeah so yes be
careful
there's no guarantees but train
back to the training partners part you
know when you the first one where you're
saying um
be careful who you train with and stuff
like that so sometimes especially like
let's say if you're older
or um even if you're a girl
and you go in and and you know you're
the only girl and
you know some people they like let's say
the guy doesn't know any better he's
going hard you can tell when he starts
to go hard
sometimes it can be awkward to kind of
say hey you know like respectfully i'm
not going to roll with you
because of you know it's kind of like
asking someone to dance and them saying
no
yeah you know like oh it's like
rejection so it's awkward so sometimes
you people will just tough it out and be
like oh just try to endure
i think if you can find you know if you
can go through that
and really look out for yourself where
you know the guy's going nuts he's
obviously usually he's not trying to go
nuts and hurt you
that's pretty rare but they don't know
any better they're a white belt or
you know whatever and they're just
bigger and stronger or whatever and
and they're going nuts you gotta you
gotta find a good tactful way to be like
hey
i respect you but i'm concerned about
like just
my injuries yeah just you know what hey
sorry i only roll with people under 130
because i have a
you know uh yeah injured rip yeah yeah
and there you go
just just is that a white lie maybe it
is
but i don't think it's a malicious white
lie
sam harris i apologize for uh telling
people to tell a little
white lie to save themselves massive
injuries catastrophic injuries
yeah but again it's like telling someone
no when they ask you to dance you can
tell white lies the fact is
you know meant for my own reasons i
don't want to dance you know
yeah but it might be okay to say oh
sorry um
i'm here with billy over there and and
so i can't dance with you
and that's actually gonna make you feel
better than just like hey you know what
actually i don't like
you yeah yeah you kind of disgust me
yeah so i'm not dancing with you walk
away
right yeah is it necessary to do that
probably not maybe the little white lie
is okay
it helps yeah again sam harris apologize
we're encouraging lying
it's like saying like i'm not gonna say
hey you're a spaz you're a liability you
might hurt me because of what you don't
know how to do
i'm not gonna roll with you that's
different you know you mean you offended
the guy yeah
most likely so actually we're actually
talking about that
while you are on the jiu jitsu mats
doing physical jiu-jitsu sometimes you
gotta throw in a little mental jiu-jitsu
in the situation and just manipulate a
little bit the mentality of your
training partners
yep and that is in the spirit of safety
indeed
because i don't think jocko would ever
say that to anybody he'd be like oh your
spaz bring it on
if i'm not mistaken we got to deal with
them people
you know next question when dealing with
new groups of folks before you go there
by the way
sometimes you should train with someone
that's really spazz and harder and
bigger than you
you should do that sometimes now you
should use caution when you do it maybe
you can get that i would rather if my
like my son if i'm gonna have him
training with someone that's big and
strong i have to train with you i'm
having trained with dean
yeah because i know that you guys will
give him enough strength to
you know but you're not gonna hurt him
because he's only 140 pounds
yes but i i don't want to give the
impression here like sometimes you got
to roll with that
sometimes you got to roll with somebody
that's big strong and doesn't know what
they're doing
just so you now you and i know what to
do there but if you're a blue belt
or a or a yeah if you're a blue belt and
a big wrestler show then you weigh
165 pounds and a wrestler shows up that
weighs 240
and it's his third day and you're a
young guy you know
it's it's a good idea to roll with that
person because they're going to do
things you aren't expecting
they're really strong they're going to
be trying really hard and
you want to be you want to be you want
to train for yourself for the unexpected
so basically don't just we i'm not
saying when i say you know watch your
training partners i'm not saying for a
normal person that's training
crawl into a safety bubble yeah while
you're on the mats no
especially people that are you know
young and fit you should be training
with
every person you can every different
body style try them out big wrestlers
small people
lanky people train with them all because
that gets you used to all those
different body styles it
improves your game yeah i'm saying if
you are very concerned about injuries
because you have a job that requires you
to
you know use your hands or walk or
whatever then you go okay you know what
i need to take the long
the long vision here they'll fight the
long war and really be selective on my
training partners
absolutely correct yes just like how i
mean just like how the question
is i'm i want to start
jiu-jitsu and i'm worried about it so
exactly
that guy use your usually yeah exactly
but just like how you said when you get
to about blue belt you got to start
introducing more challenges
in different ways and absolutely correct
man because if
if you don't if you don't and you can
let's say you're not used to let's say
you're used to the same training
partners all the time
and you train with you know blue belts
for belts
they're specific and very effective jiu
jitsu moves for
other jiu jitsu moves right so it's like
don't turn your back all these
rules that are pretty fundamental that
rarely should be broken
and we all know them so you roll with a
guy who's his third days
athletic wrestler he doesn't know those
rules but now so he puts you outside of
the whole format of jiu jitsu
and if you don't know it it's like dang
it's almost like you're just not really
working that good
you know yeah if you're not used to it
but if you are used to it you'd be like
okay
and that's such a good technique to use
with people right when you're dealing
with people
people like people's personalities
people have a personality that they
that's how they deal with things
and they get people they funnel people
into their world so
if you have to break that just step
outside their world like don't get drawn
into people's worlds right don't get
drawn into people's strengths i mean we
talk about this all the time but don't
get drawn into their strengths don't get
drawn into their way of fighting
because it's not you're not going to be
able to win that battle because you do
it all day long
right so just come at them from a
different angle usually disarmed with
somehow
instead of being confrontational this is
just normal stuff but instead of being
confrontational with somebody
take a little flank and maybe you know
massage their ego a little bit just
but that's it it's the exact same thing
if
if people have a way of doing things and
you can get outside their pattern
you have a better chance of getting a
victory yeah yeah it's crazy